[Música]
2 años después pudieron por fin regresar
al interior de la Basílica de San Pedro
después de una misa navideña fuertemente
perturbada por el covid-19 el año pasado
con solamente 200 personas esta vez eran
muchos más a pesar del fuerte aumento en
el número de casos más de 2000 fieles
pudieron escuchar al Papa Francisco
quién baso su discurso en la humildad y
la ayuda para los desfavorecidos
tuvieron la oportunidad de estar en
Belén otros no tuvieron permiso y se
quedaron cerca de casa Mazal esté en
Irak con una hoguera en misa en una
iglesia renovada en caracoles los fieles
pudieron volver a esta ciudad cristiana
invadida hace unos años por el grupo
Estado islámico
[Música]